I just love pain I've always loved pain
with the emotion Billie Eilish puts
behind her lyrics it's no surprise she's
been through her fair share of
heartbreaks but we can't help but wonder
who exactly these romances were with and
whether or not she's the real bad guy
duh well the artist has always been
carefully private about her personal
life she's left fans with hints about
her tragic love trials over the years
making it so hard to believe that Billy
is still only 18 from first kisses to
dating rumors and everything in between
let's take a look at what exactly we
know about this celebs love life born on
December 18th 2001 the Sagittarius Queen
was always interested in a career in the
entertainment industry my name is Billy
and I'm going to play a song that I made
up with this guitar the Eilish family
was so serious about her future that had
only seven-years-old her along with
brother and music partner Phineas
switched to homeschooling so they could
focus on the Arts and in the end it all
paid off Billie and Phineas turned her
small child of bedroom into a makeshift
recording studio where they recorded
iconic songs like ocean eyes and her
2019 debut album when we all fall asleep
where do we go that got her the
chart-topping international fame she's
living in 2020 but there's one question
fans have always wondered about the star
who is the inspiration for her
heart-wrenching love songs the
speculation all began after the release
of her hit wish you were gay her lyrics
I can't tell you how much I wish I
didn't want to stay I just kind of wish
you were gay sparked rumors of the celeb
sexuality and past romances fans
demanded answers on the controversy Bob
Billy of course didn't owe them an
explanation in any way she was quick to
put the rumors to rest opening up to pop
buzz I wanted to be so clear that it's
so not supposed to be an insult it
literally means that I wish he was gay
so that he didn't like me it was
actually inspired by a situation of
unrequited love she had as a teen I
wrote this song about a guy that really
was not interested in me and it made me
feel horrible ironically enough she also
revealed the same boy came out to her as
gay just a few weeks after she wrote the
song while Billy made sure to clear up
her lyrics
real quick the stars still make sure to
keep a high level of privacy when it
comes to her personal life they're being
nice but there's a lion they just don't
see she said while talking about her
fans she even had her home blurred on
Google Maps after dealing with her fair
share of stalkers and explaining that
she no longer feels 100% safe in her la
childhood home
she's so private that the only love
interest she's ever name-dropped was the
boy she shared her very awkward first
kiss with at one of her concerts she
told fans about a boy named Henry
Whitford who took her on a date for
Valentine's Day back in 2017 and left
her with a very interesting first kiss
story taking her to the roof a parking
lot for the big moments Billy explains
that's definitely a story to tell at the
dinner table for years to come it seems
like it was pretty scarring for Billy
fans were quick to find Henry on
Instagram leaving comments like on the
road to find something more magical I
see on Billy's behalf we are sure Billy
can't be that mad at him though
considering the to follow one another on
social media although Billy felt
comfortable enough dropping Henry's name
the other people she claims to have been
in love with between the ages of 15
through 18 I was in love but not at the
moment she said on many occasions that
her lyrics are penned about real and raw
experiences that means songs like when
the party's over have mysterious
romantic encounters attached to them and
we sadly may never know the full story
but we do know for sure is that she
takes love super seriously she made it
clear that singing about love is no joke
it has even fought against the idea that
young people don't know love so like you
can't feel things until you're like in
your 20s or whatever I'm like when older
people say what do you know about things
like love I know more about it than you
do because I'm feeling it for the first
time right now whereas you haven't felt
that for a long time that doesn't mean
is any less powerful but it is
definitely a different feeling
in fact her experience with love has
even helped her understand her fans
better la Henry may have been the stars
first experience in real life Billy has
explained that she once thought of
herself as being in a long-distance
relationship with Canadian icon Justin
Bieber
I'm not gonna go on before you aw and
gosh about how cute her love for him
must have been Billy warrants it was
definitely unhealthy it's not good to be
in love with someone who doesn't know
you exist
people have my meet and greets have said
Billy I feel the way you feel about
Justin Bieber about you and that blows
my mind I do not mean to be putting
anybody in the position I was in
finishing with the heart-wrenching
statement that [ __ ] hurts that was like
my first love like that was the person I
was in love with in my head he was in
love with me
it was a relationship with a person
luckily she seems to have grown out of
the one-sided romance with the Biebs
and the two had the most adorable first
meeting at Coachella back in 2019 but
while her unhealthy relationship with
beaver might have been one-sided and
completely virtual Billy has had her
fair share of toxic ones in real life as
well one even played a role in her
struggle with depression her mental
stayed back in her early teen years had
not only Billy worried for her safety
but her mother worried as well
especially when she would see things
like why am i alive written on her
daughter's walls when asked what she
thought figured her mental states back
in her early teen years Billy told
Bogues the combination of a dance injury
toxic friend group and being treated
badly in a romantic relationship for all
reasons though Billy had admitted to
being in a much better place now
remnants of how she's been treated by
boyfriends can still be seen in the way
she dresses known for her edgy wardrobe
of loose clothing Billy admits there's a
reason behind her fashion choices
according to the singer never having
felt desired in past relationships who
really contributed to her body
dysmorphia my past boyfriends never made
me feel desired none of them
she tells GQ it's a big thing in my life
that I feel I have never been physically
desired by somebody it's hard to
describe the feeling huh her closet is a
way to draw unwanted attention away from
her body and channeled the power she's
been missing I have never felt powerful
in relationships going on to explain I
dress the way I dress as I don't like to
think of you guys I mean anyone everyone
judging it or the size of it though
Billy did admit she was innocent in all
of her failed relationships I've
ever felt powerful in a relationship
well I did once and guess what I took
advantage of that person's kindness I
wasn't used to it
however she put her past behind her and
now uses her clothing more as a
statement piece to combat all her haters
my body is mine and yours is yours our
bodies are kind of the only real things
which are truly ours I get to see it and
get to show it when I want to
she even released a short film titled
not my responsibility to those
sexualizing her appearance stripping
down until she disappears into black
liquid she calls out anyone who's ever
made a statement on her body though
you've never seen in my bad
you still judge me is my value based
only on your perception or is your
opinion of me not my responsibility
although she continues to release music
made from the heart she's made it very
clear that she's driving the single lane
in 2020 and instead of focusing on
loving herself I was in love but not at
the moment she told MTV before warming
our hearts by saying I'm in love with
her me while pointing to the mirror in
front of her while there may be someone
in the future that will catch her eye
she's just not ready to explore that
side of herself right now I know I will
find somebody eventually but at the
moment I can't visualize it I feel like
I am a totally different person when I
am with someone else however the media
will be the media and there's no
shortage of dating rumors still swirling
around the artists back in 2018 rumors
of a potential romance with rapper
Danielle Abrego Lee also known as bad
baby surfaced after fans caught wind of
a photo Danielle posted on social media
referring to Billie as her girlfriend it
turned out the two were nothing but
really close friends and Billie released
his statement on social media referring
to the artist as basically family I am
NOT dating Danielle y'all stupid that's
my baby sister more girl friends rumors
came up earlier in 2020 when Billy took
a tropical trip to Hawaii in a paparazzi
video footage of Billy and bracing
another girl lost swimming surfaced and
more rumors began to circle YouTube
videos were even made about it however
people in the comments of the video put
the fire out right away saying if you
were a true Billy Eilish fan you would
know that's her best friend drew not her
girlfriend Billy never specifically
debunked these dating rumors herself but
she has made the
interesting statement that she's not
even attractive to people at the moment
people just don't do it for me it's been
months and I'm not attracted to people
anymore calling her new experience
confusing but actually kind of dope like
we mentioned earlier Billie has stepped
away from the romantic side of her life
and is falling in love with herself and
she deserves all the self-love but she's
also investing a lot of time advocating
for other things she believes in through
all of these ups and downs she's become
a huge advocate for mental health and
has on multiple occasions been vocal
about how her fans can reach out for
help
it doesn't make you weak to ask for a
friend to go to a therapist
it shouldn't make you feel weak to to
ask anyone for help and you should be
able to ask anyone for help no matter
how private Billie has been about her
romantic endeavors
she's definitely taught her fans a lot
about love and more importantly
self-love past romantic turmoil is
definitely heartbreaking but sometimes
that pain can help us grow into who were
meant to be and see what truly matters
or even become internationally known pop
stars do you have any theories on why
fans and the media are so interested in
her love life do you think she'll ever
open up more about her past
relationships let us know what you think
in the comments section below don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
ring that notification bell to keep up
to date on more videos like this one
from the things